i found out ultimately by a phone call
on a monday evening in spring and uh i
hadn't thought i'd been selected as
national i'd gone all the way through
the selection process done the final
interviews with the director general of
visa himself um and was kind of told
sure we'll let you know in a couple of
weeks a couple of weeks have come and
gone and the next thing i saw on the
internet was that the european space
agency is announcing its new core of
astronauts on wednesday this was monday
i hadn't heard anything so i hadn't been
chosen
so i was very surprised on monday night
to get the phone call literally saying
we'd like you to become an astronaut and
can you make it to paris on wednesday it
was one of the dg's staff who made the
call and i was actually out in the
garden at the time because it was a nice
spring evening and my wife came out to
meet me because she saw me on the phone
and knew that you know there was a
possibility of an important phone call
coming and so um she could tell by my
expression and the conversation that it
was obviously good news so it's one of
those moments in your life when you
realize you're making you know a huge
change for many different reasons in
terms of where you're going to live and
your future and obviously becoming an
astronaut is a massive career change and
all the responsibility that goes along
with that as well
and i think all of that that enormity
kind of hits you in one moment and
there's a whole plethora of different
emotions you're delighted and you're
excited but also you know you're you've
got some apprehension about the future
where we're going to live and
rebecca was pregnant at the time with
our first child so what's the what's the
impact on the family going to be all of
these things run through your head but
we just took them one thing at a time we
had had a serious discussion about this
just prior to the medical week during
the selection process because that's a
big week it's it's quite invasive and
you don't want to put your body through
that unless you're 100 certain about
what you're doing and also it costs a
lot of money so you don't want
the space agency to have to pay that
unless you're 100 serious that you're
going to take the job if you get offered
it so we'd had had that discussion
already and she was very supportive
and no she's the kind of character who's
always up for a challenge and
exciting futures it's i mean it's very
daunting as a rookie astronaut we spent
our initial year and a half really at
the european astronaut center and that
was just the six of my myself and my
five classmates the six of us working
together and of course we were
introduced to all the senior experienced
european astronauts so we got to talk to
them about their experiences and find
out a lot more but then when you get
assigned to a mission and you know you
come over to hear johnson space center
and also to star city and you know you
realize you're part of this enormous
machine and there's an awful lot of
pressure on you to be able to perform
and obviously there's a whole machine of
the iss program that is expecting you to
do your job very well so that can be
quite daunting but once you start the
training you realize that everybody is
extremely kind extremely supportive and
the whole system is there to set you up
for success and to make sure you can be
as good as you can be
as it happened i was in the uk when that
call came through and i was doing some
apache flying with the british army
because i i still serve as a reserve
officer and i try to get back one or two
times a year and to keep some some sort
of currency so i had just landed from a
fantastic couple of hours flying the
apache and had a call from my boss in
germany who said tim you've been
assigned to a long duration mission to
the space station
and i was i was delighted because
there had been a lot of discussion
leading up to that phone call and i knew
there was a likelihood of me being
assigned to a mission
but i thought it was probably going to
be for a short duration mission
for eight to ten days in space so to be
told no you've got a long duration
you're going for six months was i was
absolutely really delighted i was you
know really thrilled with him that's the
plum mission is that there's not
something to be said for a few short
missions as someone who loves flying and
you know
like would you rather be doing a couple
of short missions or is a long one the
plum mission i think there's a ricky
astronaut any mission's a good mission
and uh i'm not taking anything away from
the short missions because of course
before
the space station most missions were
short missions other than the russians
who were flying on the mere space
station but we had a many many shuttle
missions before that were short duration
and and several sawyers missions were
also short duration and and you can
learn an awful lot in a short duration
your training times that much shorter so
maybe in a space of three years you
could fit in you know two short duration
missions now we're moving towards these
long six-month duration missions of
living and working in space um for me i
think i i was much you know happier with
the long duration mission for me this is
a real experience to actually get to
know what it is like to spend that much
time in space
you're an astronaut and proud of being
it's a really famous job and everyone
wants to talk to you and ask you
questions and things like that what's it
like being an astronaut but having not
been in space and having you know you're
doing interviews and meeting people and
all this sort of stuff
but you can't answer these questions
that everyone has
that's a really good question and i
think i found that harder in the early
days
because especially as i i was much more
comfortable being a test pilot and that
was my expertise and i was kind of at
the the pinnacle of my career as a test
pilot very confident about what i was
doing there what i was talking about and
suddenly i'm being asked to i'm being
called an astronaut when i haven't flown
in space which seems very strange and
i'm being asked to comment on all of
these things
as i've gone through the training
process you actually gained so much more
experience about what you're training
and there are so many great things to
talk about
of what's going on here on the ground
and what we're doing i mean i've spent
12 days living under water off the coast
of florida on nasa's nemo mission um
assimilating an asteroid mission spent a
week living in a cave in sardinia
simulating a mission with other
international astronauts as well we're
training all the time with our
international partners and so the
training itself is such an experience
that there's plenty to talk about
obviously you know the icing on the cake
is the fact that you actually get to fly
to space and that's when you'll really
be able to relate your experiences to
what it's like to go on a mission the
actual mission itself is it one of these
things that it can't come quick enough i
can't wait i can't wait or because you
know it's this great moment in your life
that may not happen again it may be a
one-off but you know it's going to be
this amazing life do you almost want to
push it back a bit and sort of delay the
pleasure like how do you feel about that
um i think that that's a great question
i've never been asked that before but i
think the timing is is perfect because
um you obviously need a certain amount
of time to feel confident and to feel
prepared for your mission but at the
same token i don't want to push it any
further to the right because you know
you're not only excited about the
mission you're waiting for it to happen
but until it happens you're an unflown
astronaut and there's always a risk that
something might happen to you you might
become medically unfit um i mean let's
hope not but something could happen to
the space station that renders the
mission uh unattainable so no it's one
of those things that that it's just in
the right place i'd be ready for the
mission and you know that that's a great
time for it
i'm sure you've heard of the astronaut
prayer of you know god just please don't
let me mess up it's one of those cases
that there are there are many
opportunities where you can do things
wrong
and that's what the training is for
that's why we train for two and a half
years